now I guess I am live here
blah blah blah new I apologize for being
late if someone could say something just
to confirm that I am live maybe put it
in the chat box here ah ok so they still
there we are
alright we're here okay first of all I
am also I was told that I should do
something here we'll see what happens ok
so I apologize for being late I had an
interview in Italian with a Italian
blogger podcaster guy and we had a
fabulous discussion and I said that I
needed to get a get away and time to
start this and it just went on and on
and on and then I we couldn't get zoom
going and I have to record it and I
wasn't sure if I can get this started if
it ruin my recording and stuff anyway
I'm here so we are going to streak here
and I want to explain what we're trying
to do with these 90-day challenges and
streaks and so forth is so language
learning is a matter of habit okay and
let me know if there's any problem with
the sound it's so difficult like I'm
talking at the computer and I don't know
if it's all working out fine but what do
we see I don't see any negatives oh yeah
what's up ok so language learning is a
matter of creating habits you have to
create habits with a new language these
are new habits new linguistics habits
new almost cultural habits but you also
have to create the habit of studying
languages it becomes a an activity
that's that's rewarding that's almost
addictive and so by forcing yourself to
go for like a 3 month period you're not
only going to create new habits in the
language or improve your habits in the
language you're gonna create some study
habits which I think can be you know you
carry them with you period
now three months is kind of a good
period I have found that in many
languages three months no I guess I'm on
this three months I find in many
languages three months gets you through
that first period if you're starting
from scratch it gets you to where the
language is no longer strange you have
some concept of how the language works
you hopefully have bombarded your brain
with the language as I did with Turkish
for three months starting from scratch
I listened over 100 hours I read 150,000
words all of this is bombarding my brain
I'm not you know I had my last you know
lesson in Turkish I made a lot of
mistakes I can go back in there and
gradually improve what is we got a
message here I don't know what that was
anyway justice epic in here anyway so
now I lost my train of thought here so
yeah the three months is sort of where
you familiarize yourself with the
language then from there to gain all the
vocabulary you need to become call it be
to fluent able to understand the
conversation around you that's a long
trip it might be two or three three
month periods where you want to maintain
your streak and you want to work on your
vocabulary you want to refer again to
the sort of grammar rules that you've
looked at that five ten times and still
you can't get it right and so that and
and continue to acquire more vocabulary
so that you can listen to more
meaningful material because if you'd
listened to more meaningful material
again your bombard in your brain with
the language and gradually everything is
becoming natural because you can't you
can't rely on your ability to remember a
rule or remember a tensor remember
things because when you're speaking like
I'm speaking now in English it has to
come out naturally and you have to rely
on your brain
the brain will gradually acquire all
these things but you have to put that
effort into it and so I think these
streaks of three months even if at the
end of the three months like now with
Turkish I've left it ha what is this now
boy
I keep on getting messages on slack and
I don't know if they're relevant or not
no 1009 let's see what okay I mean I get
the impression that it's working so
let's continue here so what is this so
I'm getting messages by parting me not
good
I I will rely on comments from the
people who are watching me I'm assuming
that it's all working fine so good and I
will answer these questions once I
finished what I have to say here so what
I don't know anyway um yeah where are we
now
so we're going to I'm gonna share with
you what I'm gonna do in my street is
here okay I had three months of Turkish
I spent a good hour and a half a day an
hour of listening and it's so easy to
get the listening in God just a second
[Music]
it's so easy to get to listening in
because I listen 10 minutes in the
morning making breakfast I listen in the
car I get my hour of listening in there
are areas that I don't understand that
motivates me then to go and read and
work on link to try and learn the words
and phrases and so the listening
triggers at all so in terms of
maintaining your streak make sure you
you set yourself up to listen one of the
easiest ways to do that in what I have
found is
if I have a course in link it could be
my many stories in Turkish it could even
yeah many stories would be a good
example it might be something that I
have imported from YouTube where we are
able to use a the link extension to the
browser extension to bring stuff into
link and then make that a course so I
imported four items in Turkish from
YouTube so then this becomes a course
well in the course you can choose listen
to the audio on my on my app you can do
it on the site as well but on my iPhone
I go listen to the audio so now I
automatically have if it's the mini
stories sixty stories so I go listen to
the audio I make sure I don't always
start at lesson one because I'm always
listening to lesson one so I go to
lesson 10 lesson 20 I've got that with
me or if it's the TED Talks which I
imported from YouTube in Turkish then I
start listening to them so I've got the
listening going it's going and that's
just gonna add up so the reason I get to
an hour or more a day or a hundred hours
over the 90 day period is that it's easy
for me so make things easy it's easy to
set up to listen and when I listen I
don't understand things and so that then
drives me to go and and read and link
and so it's fairly it's like falling out
of bed it's not that difficult to get
yourself to be active everyday and the
important thing in language learning is
is is being active that's why it makes
me measure people's level of activity if
you are active in the language you will
learn and you know you may not learn as
much as you would like you may not be as
good as you would like but you are
learning you are learning always if you
are listening and reading and speaking
because ultimately eventually you have
to speak a lot and so it may be that in
this streak or this challenge that
you're on you are already past that
first three-month period or you're
wanting to become familiar with the
language maybe you're at a level now
where you actually need to speak a lot
because at a certain point you have to
speak a lot if you want to speak well
and so that means maybe either setting
up more conversations online
or trying to find people to talk to and
I have found whereas you know I didn't
use to talk so early the many stories if
I work them very hard as I've done not
with Greek and with Arabic and Persian
and Turkish it gets me talking earlier
Jesus something is not working well I'm
on live chat ok so yeah so what I find
very good is that I get my I have my
conversation with with my tutor and then
I get a report back and I review that
and so that provides me with more input
and and allows me to address in the
areas where I have trouble ok no I'm
going to read your questions and try to
answer them so bla bla bla
ok if you are at here's the first
question here I am at 20,000 on words in
French where I am on the hockey stick
you are well on your way you're on the
long I figure I talked about the sort of
upside down hockey stick and you know
the first three months you're getting
familiar with the language you're you're
saying wow I can you know say things in
this language and then in the next long
period it just takes a long time to
accumulate words if you're in 20,000
words you're well on your way the first
stage that getting familiar with the
language stage typically three to five
thousand eight thousand words okay
sounds good videos frozen well there's
nothing much I can do I'm just gonna
continue here okay so studio dos idiomas
Indiana Territory Ramada Hotel continue
are
como puede volver a game you know what
how do I get back into it if I've
stopped doing it you just have to force
yourself create new habits it's all
about habits listening is the easiest
thing to get back into um it's just too
difficult for me to read Arabic on the
fly like this the lead thing from email
is incorrect and then I look forward to
Poland lying little platform great the
fear to speak how you overcome the fear
speak just force yourself it's all about
communicating and the more you fear the
less the language is gonna enter your
brain I will post the Italian interview
yes I have never heard of Japanese from
zero what do you think about learning
Chinese characters with pictures or
stories not much I haven't done that can
you learn language by listening
listening is an important part of it
okay email YouTube is incorrect want to
say thank you for your work there are 73
Chloe's people question
did you record your first session with
your Turkish tutor in the first session
know it sounds weird I've read the
linguist and transplants thanks to link
ok media doesn't is it possible for
three months to achieve B to a level and
German from scratch Oh from a - no I
think B - is a is a very high level so I
think if you're at a - you're looking at
at least another six months to get to B
- I think depends how much you put in
every day is this impossible to start
reading novels in Japanese and Chinese
after one year of learning four hours a
day yes it's possible do you think
writing a lot improves speaking accuracy
definitely okay the the cool link shirt
we are stay tuned we'll be letting you
know how you get that I want to learn
English but I do not know how to start
get on link
I went learn English okay but the high
seek method my son mark did the high
seek method I had didn't use it a lot of
people like it you have to you obviously
have to you have to put in the effort to
learn the characters
what are your contents in Turkish what
we have the many stories actually we
have a lot of content in Turkish some
that I we have our many stories other
people have contributed content I have
brought in videos from YouTube I have
brought in dialogues from Netflix
various Turkish series so if you go into
our library you'll find lots do you have
any advice for someone who speaks
English and French who really wants to
pick a third language
oh so which language you're gonna have
to decide there's nothing I can tell you
about what your motivation is learn the
language you're most motivated to learn
okay I can understand one percent of
English but cannot speak like a native
speaker what's the solution
there is no solution it's not realistic
to expect to speak like a native speaker
worried about understanding which you
say you understand and communicating it
Kenna's language learning method I don't
know I've never heard of it alright a
second how to stop making grammar
mistakes it's a slow process review the
rules from time to time go back to
listening and reading try writing being
correct it helps a little bit ultimately
you have to notice your own mistakes I'm
trying to learn Portuguese and Spanish
simultaneously good luck b2 in German
starting from scratch one and half years
yes that is possible here goes really
tricky question which language that
you've learned did you enjoy the least
the enjoyment depends on the content
that is available so those languages for
which I'm able to find interesting
content are the ones that I enjoy the
most those languages the difficulty is
like say in Korean or Arabic where it's
easy to get past that first stage where
you have a sense of the language and
then the authentic material is very
difficult obviously if you're an English
speaker learning Spanish you can go from
the beginner material to authentic
material very quickly because 50% of the
words are recognizable that's not the
case in Korean Arabic Chinese so those
if you can't get that intermediate level
of content then it's less enjoyable that
has been a challenge in Korean and so
far in Arabic all languages bring me joy
wait a second now it seems to jump
around which number okay which are your
thoughts on reading a lot
I don't do it but reading out loud but
some people do it I think it spend time
with the language it I I think it has
its benefits the stories any respond
you're positive mrs. Farren okay to
Allah should I start having classes with
the tutor I mean I finding that the
tutor once or twice a week three times a
week is very helpful especially if the
tutor gets you talking and if the tutor
since your report
hopefully recorded so you can go over
what you said hey yarda how are you how
is your check well I've been away from
my check and very difficult so have a
number of languages that are in a
dormant stage because I haven't used
them and but I feel I mean I understand
that sometimes read check newspaper
articles online if I were to reactivate
my check it would come back but right
now it would be very difficult for me
after learning French how much easier
would be learnt and easier I can't tell
you how much okay uh a question here
standardized tests how useful are they I
don't do them I learned from my own
reasons I don't really care where I
stack up on these tests if a test
stimulates you good anything that forces
you to study is good and that includes
these streaks or 90-day challenges it
just forces you to study and hopefully
develop good habits how to speed up the
learning process by comprehensible
comprehensive input just expose yourself
to as much comprehensible input as you
can it seems to jump around here which
we'll learn first process or rule
phonological e I don't understand the
question
okay with regard to stories we have I'm
gonna talk about that tomorrow in my
video but we've decided to hold off on
adding stories because it's so much work
it was so much work to get the many
stories going to control the quality the
audio and so forth we've decided to hold
off on it and instead maybe set up some
kind of a page sort of like a wiki type
page where if people want to experiment
in creating stories they can put them
there and people can look at them and if
some of them are good I just don't know
what we're gonna do with this whole mini
story thing but I'm just not prepared to
put the same amount of effort in that we
did to come up with you know 60 stories
in 30 languages it's it's an awful lot
of work
I'm kind of backing off from that which
one of the English skills is above all I
don't know what that means but if you're
saying which language skill is the most
important its to me its comprehension if
you have good comprehension the other
skills will come when importing into
link to create your stories okay I we
don't import to create stories we have
our mini stories plus any individual
learner can bring in anything they want
for their own use so whatever they find
typically these things cannot be shared
because there are copyright issues but
whatever is of interest to them they
bring it in and if it's too difficult or
if they don't find it interesting they
bring something else in it's up to each
individual member learner to choose what
they want to bring in okay James Cook he
likes it when I talk about teaching
because he is a teacher of various
languages
what dialect of Arabic have you been
learning I've gone after you know Fattah
because there's material on the internet
you know websites podcasts because it's
a bit of a base so that if I ever wanted
to focus on Levantine Arabic Egyptian
Arabic then I could do so hello from
Uzbekistan greetings from Russia
thank you I still have fond memories of
visiting Russia in June a few years ago
now I lost that again where did that go
boy it seems to pop out here we are hi
Steve thank you very good do you think
learning a language before traveling to
a country makes one's experience much
more rewarding absolutely and I think
the expectation that you can simply
travel to the country and then learn is
unrealistic I had the experience in
Vietnam I grabbed some phrase book and I
found that I was unable to use anything
or learn anything while in Vietnam for a
week on the other hand before going to
Greece we were in Crete for a week with
my wife I put in a good six months of
learning Greek and when I was there I
was able to communicate so you have to
have a certain level in order to make
that visit a rewarding fun talking to
locals and be that it can actually help
you improve in the language I have easy
listening and conversation but I have a
hard time reading more each page I do
not understand I don't understand the
question I'm done reading more each page
I do not understand I mean with regard
to understanding it's a gradual process
so you just have to keep going and trust
yourself have you been in Turkey I was
in Turkey I was in Turkey with my wife
in 1975 haven't been back since and now
I'm very motivated to go there because
that is one thing that happens when you
learn languages is it worth listening to
podcast see if you can only understand
50% I think so
but when I listen to something where I
understand 50% ideally I would like to
access the transcript so that I can get
the parts that I'm missing and very
often those are very important parts so
I experimented with different things
like putting them on what do you call it
you know these automatic transcription
sites but the quality of this
transcripts is very uneven so I prefer
to look for things where I can find a
transcript when in the early stages of
learning a language and searching for
literature do you recommend at all or
our children level might be a silly
question okay I do not find children
material easier than adult material
because it's often there's animals and
there's stuff that's not so easy I
prefer to go with something like our
many stories where there's lots of
repetition but it's not really written
for children and then I try to find
things that are of interest but I don't
necessary often nonfiction is easier
than fiction and I'd not haven't found
children's stories to be easier okay who
know routine eyes pacifica basically
what I do is I get up I listen because
it's easy to do we're making breakfast
or if I'm going to the office or
whatever working out this then triggers
this desire
like I didn't understand something so
then I want to go and read in order to
find the words that I'm missing so
that's basically the routine and then
once or twice a week I get on with an
online tutor and talk and then I have a
record of all my conversations going
back three months six months and I can
review those and kind of relive those
conversations it's more important to
keep improving when we already know
fifteen thousand words in English for
example I'm sure I focus on reading or
listening or what's your opinion I don't
have a tutor okay if you have fifty
thousand words I think you should get a
tutor and that's gonna improve improve
your speaking it's also going to create
for you some more learning content
focused on the words that you don't or
that you have trouble with words and
phrases because a good tutor will send
you a nice long report fifteen twenty
words phrases that you didn't use
correctly hopefully and you can ask your
tutor to record that so you can focus in
on things that you have trouble if what
I find is if I go back and look at my
you know conversation reports over X
period of time I make the same mistakes
week after week so it's good and
eventually I stopped making those
mistakes so it's a good way to create
content for you to learn from input
material that is focused on areas where
you have trouble
so start speaking and continue your
reading and hopefully get on to
something of interest to you to read and
listen any advice for learning German no
different than learning any other
language boy pops up here
now we're didn't go boy boy it seems to
just need to zoom up and then I lose my
place here hmm oh here we are okay about
Mandarin Chinese I'm at an intermediate
level but I feel I've been stuck for a
while how can I get out of this Plateau
greetings from PR Puerto Rico I presume
I mean that's a common problem in
learning languages we get stuck several
things first of all get yourself if you
can find something of real interest to
you so you forget about how you're doing
in Mandarin get totally wrapped up in
something of interest that you're
listening to and reading you can also go
and do another language and come back
because then when you come back the
Mandarin again will be fresh for you you
know I keep on saying you know we need
both repetition and novelty so if you're
pounding your head against a brick wall
with Chinese you don't feel you're
getting anywhere go to another language
now you'll be even anxious to get back
to Chinese you'll come back you'll have
lost a little bit but very quickly you
will move forward because it'll be fresh
for your brain I can speak when is
matter see I was just linking in I saw
your online thanks for everything nice
to watch your videos hello from Turkey
loved learning Turkish I'm getting back
to Turkish but I'm on this sort of you
know next is Arabic and I'm keen to get
back to my Arabic then I'm gonna be key
to get back to my Persian then I'll be
keen to get back to my Turkish oh
because another thing about one of the
key principles to mastering a new
foreign language from far away where it
is not spoken well most of the languages
I learned I'm learning from far away I
do it on link I do lots of listening and
reading okay Vincent the French many
stories yes we have been delinquent with
these many stories we have German and
French maybe a few others where they
haven't been completed we have been
relying on volunteers and we've just
decided we're gonna go out and find
people to do them so we get them done
sorry for being late
they will be completed
what was the best in your linguistic
career it's all fun I can't say ah
Christian Martinez I'm a teacher to
English and French I've talked all my
students into using Lync I don't trust
other platforms anymore thank you very
much that's good and we do have a sort
of program for schools link for the
classroom so you could send us a email
to customer service and just to see if
there's anything we can do to make it
better for you to import you have to be
official member of link because I use
link but I don't but the packet yes you
have to be a paying member of link to be
able to import can I really learn a
language and hold a 15 minute
conversation in 90 days like Benny says
well I did it in Turkish you can check
out my YouTube channel and you'll see
the conversation I had in Turkish for
about 45 minutes after 90 days of
studying Turkish on link hey from
Stockholm hey will this life be the will
this light be on the channel when it's
finished yes I think so seems
interesting but I don't much time yes in
red positive unions Polsky okay thank
you fallen boy and there's a language I
want to get back to is polish for sure
have you ever felt like you were wasting
that you waste your time with the
language because what you learned was
useless or because you never got to an
intermediate level no whatever I put
into a language it's there it might you
know I might forget a few things it's
always there I can always go back to it
I can go back to my many stories to get
back up and then I can go pursue our
interesting content it's all money in
the bank I have different accounts in my
bank and I can go back to any of them
and increase their value never wasted
you use mnemonic Mount Nemo techniques
to study vocabulary no I don't I don't
know what is your level in Swedish I
think I'm probably a b2 I mean a quite
comfortable speaking Swedish but to have
some lacks my gaps in my vocabulary
after backing off the new mini story can
you maybe think of a way to let people
put and translate new stories on your
website okay first of all you already
have the capability of putting stories
content into
so that already exists you can import
stuff you own the content you know the
copyright to anything that you have
created you put it into our library for
that language obviously it should be a
native speaker you can earn a small
number of points from doing that so
that's all that's there maybe we'll just
stay with that I don't know but I am
backing off the idea of undertaking to
work with people who are gonna submit
stories and we're gonna check the
stories and check the quality it's just
too much work I think part our emphasis
at link now is to make it easier for
people to get to the authentic content
which could be YouTube Netflix or for
Asian languages Viki that's kind of our
emphasis we have some things in the
works that are gonna make the library
easier to deal with and I think we want
to spend our time there what do you do
with your saved phrases in link I review
them I see them when they come up again
you know when I'm reading but I will
often review my links that's one of the
phrases rather I'll often review them
and go through in the flashcard
sometimes in dictation it just helps me
get a get a hold of these phrases when I
see them as phrases Rena katana link
mini stories are awesome
great thank you from Brazil I study
Mandarin with integrated Chinese love
these books blah blah blah calculus you
would know so to cover sure getting from
b1 to b2 in a speak okay getting from b1
to b2 is a question a of vocabulary and
familiarity with the language continuing
your exposure input but that's when you
want to start speaking more to speak
well you have to speak a lot
I need a native speaker I guess you have
to look on the internet I'm presenting
to you speak Portuguese and following
poco what do you think about aja titi I
don't know much about it so no comment
no experience in learning kazakh at some
point when i get good enough in turkish
i'm curious to explore how other Turkic
family languages are different from each
other whether it be AZ area or kazakh or
and so forth YouTube channel you're
gonna have fur Italian you're gonna have
to search yourself at YouTube we are
going to try to see if we can create
lists of resources in different
languages that people can import into
linked using our browser extension
that's one of things we're planning to
do okay I'm not gonna be doing anything
on Portuguese for the time being it's
not a language that I speak very well
but you know the dilemma if you are
learning more languages are you going to
try to improve in Italian or Portuguese
or some of these languages to russian or
am i gonna explore new languages right
now i'm interested in exploring new
languages because i'm discovering a
whole new world and Arabic and Persian
and Turkish right now for example and I
find that interesting I am motivated by
what interests me that's what drives me
I'm not motivated by the desire to say
my Portuguese is now very good my
Portuguese is okay I can communicate do
you know when that time is right to move
on to a new language I'd like to learn
Turkish or Indonesian but I'm afraid
I'll quickly forget my progress in other
languages so I move on when I feel like
it there is no rule for me you may have
different motivations and I don't worry
about what I forget because it is still
there it gets a little rusty one thing
that is sure if you learn something then
forget it
and then relearn it you will have it
there stronger so the fact that I'm
gonna have to relearn something that I
once learned it's like you know I don't
know if you do cross-country skiing but
the first time you're going along you
are creating the trail but the second
time you come through the trail is
already there it goes much faster so
doesn't bother me no I never worry about
whether I forget and sometimes it's good
like and that's why I'm experimenting
now with going you know three languages
Turkish Arabic and Persian because it
there's there's this whole issue that I
was referred to you know repetition
versus novelty sometimes if you're
staying with the one language and you
kind of feel you're not making any
progress go to another language
refreshes things and now you're anxious
to get
back to the first one advice on learning
English is the same as advice on
learning every other languages
Neha wash your time around okay hello
Taiwan thank you for the feedback
there's one way to overcome ABC more you
say yeah well as Christiane Martinez
says you know any of these tests TOEFL
TOEIC any of these the fundamental skill
is comprehension if you can if you can
listen and understand read and
understand quickly then all of a sudden
everything happens faster you can
respond quickly you have time to do the
test you're giving answers to
grammatical questions based on the sense
of the language rather than trying to
remember rules boy why does it keep
popping up like that now where was it so
I do
thing that causes everything she weighs
no I go back up again
was it okay how many years you need to
spend abroad in order to reach a great
level of fluency there is no rule you
don't necessarily have to go abroad
either
all these questions how long does it
take to do this and that I'm not a great
fan of them focus on enjoying the
process if you have a chance to be in
the country where the language is spoken
fine take full advantage and if you're
not find other ways to create a language
world around you humor comedy difficult
to understand yeah it can be a little
more difficult any of these you know
situations where you're heavily into
another culture are more difficult to
understand if you're talking to three or
four people it's a little easier than
say understanding a comedy on TV which
language has for you been the easiest to
learn well of the languages that I've
done recently would have to be Romanian
any language where you have 60 70 %
vocabulary similar to the language you
already know is going to be easy
do you use you goof or Chinese I don't
study Chinese okay now here he's young
would like me to explain of this in
Chinese but I'm not gonna do that
because at this point the common
language here is English so I'm gonna
stay with that is Russian grammar more
complicated than German to me it was to
me it was the complexity of the cases
there's just more cases than in German
and just more strange rules the verbs of
motion they aspect the verbs yeah should
we learn kanji first I think it's
important to to start on the kanji I
started with the hiragana but then I
knew the kanji whether you do it from
day one or after two months doesn't
really matter but I believe that to be
good in to be good in in Japanese
Chinese you need to read and therefore
you need the characters
yeah South by Russian grammar is much
more difficult absolutely and through
coded osteoma squalus it's all the same
you know input that's what I talk about
all the time what do you think of
recording one's own voice based on
reading tasks one already understands
but I think I guess you used to
listening to yourself transmitting
naturally I think it can be a good thing
to do I did it for a you know her
earlier languages like French and
Chinese I think it's good to do and to
try to imitate the intonation so I have
a short text maybe listen to it saying
link listen to a sentence or even a
paragraph and then try and record
yourself hitting that same intonation
I'm just not good enough to read Arabic
here in small font on the screen so I
can't respond to that
Arabic question kcon tienda reporting
over sathya so the idea the idea is that
the tutor in a conversation will list
phrases ideally phrases sentences where
you had trouble 10 15 20 and record them
and that's the report so then I that
then becomes content at link I study it
I listen to it several times and
hopefully I don't make the same mistakes
again probably I will make the same
mistakes again but in time I'll make
them less often can I learn Japanese in
English at the same time sure uh if I
have a favorite period in history I
don't have a favorite period in history
I get recently I've become furious about
the history of the country that I'm
learning but other than that I find
ancient history fascinating I find
medieval history I find you know
relatively you know recent history every
yeah you know 20th century it's all
interesting to me hello from Kazakhstan
what I mean is how do you get your
conversation report is a request that
the teacher has to describe okay if the
teacher is at link then that's a
condition the teacher will not get paid
unless the teacher submits the
conversation report if you're on with
someone that you too are these I talk he
you'll have to make your arrangements
with them I have found them very
accommodating I don't do shadowing so I
can't comment advice for mastering
Russian cases since I haven't mastered
them I don't know but I used to tag
phrases which had different cases I
would try to look up the if I had some
doubts about what the case was I would
look it up and so that I gradually
become more and more aware but
ultimately I think it's just a matter of
having heard certain phrases so often
that certain cases just seem naturally
correct if you have to think about what
the case is it's a lot more difficult uh
well I when I said here you've always
been I did once what changed okay
I had always had the position that it
requires so much concentrated effort to
learn that you're better to kind of
maintain that intensity in order to get
somewhere in the language and I think
that's still true but nowadays for
example with the many stories it's so
easy to get started in a new language
and I'm at a stage where I want to
explore different languages so I just
thought I would do this experiment of
doing three languages again I am going
three months at a time on each language
so it's not like I'm doing three
languages at the same time the same day
and I just want to explore that and see
to what extent you know
whether that's good or not good I mean
it is true that we can be like I was
studying Arabic and after a while I felt
I wasn't getting anywhere because again
this is this tremendous gap between the
easy material and then the authentic
material and there's nothing in between
so after a while it's tiring to go over
the stuff that you already know and then
to go after to something very difficult
that's got 50% unknown you know words in
it so then I went into Persian because
it was fun so basically it's just
whatever whatever I don't have to I'm
not writing an exam on any of these I
just do what interests me cheapest so do
I need to teach speak to someone who
only speaks polish I don't know what I
would like to do eventually is I don't
think I need to do that if when if I'm I
would love to go to Poland and before
going to Poland I would spend maybe a
month or two refreshing my polish
including talking online with a pola
tutor get my level up and then I go to
Poland and if I were there for two weeks
speaking to people in Polish that would
bring my level up and I would enjoy my
visit more as I need novelty especially
since I'm learning French aren't enough
for too long without much results yeah
so the novelty that's interest is
there's no novelty thing you can get to
the stage where you feel you're not
making any progress and you get tired of
learning the language because you're not
making the progress then you go to
another language then you're kind of
anxious to get back to that other one
that's what I'm finding a bit with the
Arabic version of Turkish I'm reading a
book and every page I don't know 25
words how many do you think is ideal 25
is a lot and enough sense that's why
that's why we created link tag I had
books here in Spanish and there would be
five or 10 words on every page that I
didn't understand and then I thought gee
if there is some way that I could read
and I just look up that word because the
problem is you look up those words in a
dictionary which is time-consuming and
as soon as you close the dictionary
you've forgotten what was there
how many sessions did I have with my
turkey tutor well I had three tutors and
I looked it up I had a total of 15
sessions so the final sort of exit
lesson was the 15th lesson that I'd had
over the three-month period and I
however and I made a lot of mistakes in
my 45-minute conversation in Turkish but
I can assure you that that session was
much much better than my first session
and every session I just got better and
better how well do I understand Danish
and Norwegian I understand Norwegian a
lot better than Danish I love listening
to Danish I still remember Babette's
feast and I think it's just a matter of
not having heard it a lot if I were to
go to Denmark I would do Danish at link
I would acquire some of the vocabulary
that's different or or words that are
pronounced so whatever you know that I
don't understand what the word is even
though I know the word and then I think
if I did that then I would be able to
understand Danish right now Norwegian is
easier again there's different kinds of
Norwegian
what do you think of listening and
writing what you have listened for
example audiobooks yeah it may be good
but I don't have the discipline to do it
so I like doing what's easy listening is
easy reading is easy writing I should do
but I'm too lazy I have no need yeah so
what languages were able to learn
extremely quickly due to similarity so
it's very interesting I've it may be
because we had the many stories or we
had link was better or whatever but it
was quicker for me to learn Romanian
than to learn Portuguese from Spanish I
don't know why maybe I became a better
language learner
maybe Portuguese and Spanish are so
similar that that inhibits me
whereas Romanian seemed like it went
very very quickly hey what do you think
about learning a third language by using
a second language instead of mother
tongue yeah I mean I find that if you
have a third language which you know
well so that you're not having to look
up words so if I use French too
another language that would be fine I
buy stuff from Casa miel which is all
basic and French learning Ukrainian
using Russian is helpful because it
gives you a sense of which words are
different yeah as long as that you had
you're strong enough in that third
language how do you learn languages
where you don't understand the text what
do you use initially I use the many
stories I mean I've done it for Persian
four four five languages not Greek
Arabic Turkish I just get on here's a
story it's four minutes long I go
through I know no words I look up the
words I listen to it it's still noise I
read it look up the words I start to
piece together the meaning of that story
I listen to it again I understand a
little more then I'm bored so I go to
the second story I do the same and then
go to the third and the fourth and the
fifth and I go back to the first and lo
and behold after a month or so all of
this stuff becomes comprehensible so
that it because there's so much
repetition in the many stories that's
how I initiate myself to new languages
is there any way to use link if you were
me if you study a lot or get points or
rewards I don't understand the question
I don't understand the question
if you how to stay dedicated when you
are not getting results well very often
that's why we measure activity if you're
being active you are pounding stuff into
your brain and it'll eventually activate
so as long as you're maintaining your
streak if you're listening if you're
reading everything is okay don't be too
hard on yourself it as my favorite
neuroscientist manfred spitzer says the
brain learns but it learns slowly just
drawing microg you thank you for
inspiring ever since finally I
consistently worked on improving great
well thank you that's very kind of you
and yeah we just have to keep at it keep
at it and and we have to believe that
it's worth it I believe that we can do
it and believe that it's a valuable
thing to do which it is I found that
when I speak too much my listening
skills tail off what do you think well
you know if you focus on speaking
you can get to where you can say certain
things and so we have a limited amount
of time to spend on language learning if
we focus on speaking certain saying
certain things and using what little bit
we have that is actually taking away
from the time that we can spend on
listening and acquiring vocabulary and
so forth so I think you have to decide
where you want to spend your time by me
focusing on the many stories and
speaking early
I am accumulating vocabulary less
quickly I think then if I spent more
time on listening and reading so
eventually we have to do it all and it's
it's more a matter of doing what you're
most motivated to do because the key
thing is to stay active if you think
there is diminished returns you study
more than about an hour I haven't found
that Jason because okay so I listen an
hour the hour is when I'm making
breakfast or driving or working out that
drives me then to read and so it ends up
it's it's an hour of listening it's 3040
minutes of reading and if I'm really if
I get to the stage where I'm really
interested in what I'm reading or
listening to then I just keep going and
so I don't find that when you're tired
of it put the book down okay hello from
Ukraine by the way I had a great visit
Oksana had a great visit in Ukraine I
loved it there the people are friendly
and the food is good and quite
inexpensive and I've now been to Nepal
and Don Basque and Kiev and and l'viv
and Chen FC and so forth anyway advice
on how can I prepare for my si one
business English exam next spring and
where could I find material study
material okay so I mean you have to do I
still believe that okay you need the
better the more you read the better
you're right the more you listen the
better you speak so the input is
tremendously important in improving your
output you still have to write you still
have to speak and the more you write and
the more you speak the better but you
can't always be speaking you can't
always be writing but the listening and
reading is easier to do
you have to do a lot of listening and
reading and you can find material I
would it depends on where your
vocabulary is I would bring material in
from the internet from papers academic
paper a business-related papers I would
save words and phrases that you want to
use that that make your text more
powerful more native-like I would listen
to them where audio is available so that
you're driving all of that into your
brain but I would also read away from
the computer again variety is good so
it's one thing to read on the computer
with access to you know online
dictionaries where you can import it
into link or you can say phrases all of
that is good but you should also read
paper books or other business-related
materials you just bombard your brain
with business-related
material so like you had a great visit
in Bratislava and we all went skiing in
the Tatras mountains okay do you know
English sign up do you think their
method I don't know these other apps do
you prepare some news features for link
what we're working on right now is
improving the library how we present
content how we grade out the less
popular material so people see the more
popular material how we present it you
know visually to make it more pleasant
we're gonna help people find content
that they can bring in using our browser
extension in the various languages that
they're doing and we're gonna try to
present that in a way that's more
appealing the whole idea is that that
content is a major driver of people's
interest in language learning and we
feel we have to do a better job on how
we present content I'm using a person
I'm waiting for ty to be added that and
learn ty some people are using other
language slots it's not an ideal way to
do it the best thing is if somehow we
can find people and maybe we should just
if there's strong interest in time maybe
we'll just have to pay people to give us
the 60 mini stories in ty and then
we would be able to launch taeyeon link
greeting from Stockholm hey if I
understand out some de taille air
mini-boss Siwon playing is God I would
if you can understand everything that
I'm saying then you are c1 because
comprehension is the key skill and even
if you struggle to speak if you were to
start speaking more you would quickly
reach that level because comprehension
if you can understand what the native
speaker is saying and the native speaker
has quite a large vocabulary I believe
that that takes you high B to C one can
you learn French in a year if you don't
Spanish definitely how do you best
handle text that is 90% unknown words
I'm starting Spanish and God Harry
Potter book I'm native English speaker
faith yeah I wouldn't start with Harry
Potter I would start with our many
stories I would start you know because
don't forget that you know there is the
sort of frequency thing the high
frequency words appear very often and
the frequency declines very quickly so I
have found in my own case that working
with the mini-story first before moving
on to authentic material has worked for
me how do you not mix closely related
languages example Portuguese in Spanish
I mix them unavoidable I don't worry
about it the goal is comprehension and
communication what are some of your tips
for traditional language teachers you
know it's hard for me to say cuz I
haven't been in that situation but I
know teachers there were some of the
long Fest in Montreal who use various
comprehensible input techniques in their
classroom storytelling and I think it
would be useful to do some research on
comprehensible input ci activities which
is changing how languages are taught in
the classroom
after learning Hangul what is the next
step for you well learning Hangul is
just a basic
precondition you have to learn Hangul
very early this is the Korean script and
then it's just a matter of lots of
listening and reading that the
difficulty right now for me and what I
want to do in Korean now that our
you know link has improved I can now go
to YouTube find Korean presentations
let's say or a drama and I can import
them into link and study that as content
the problem for me has been the sort of
lack of intermediate content accessible
content I'm not doing Korean right now
but if I were to go back to Korea and
then I would focus on finding content
that is interesting and accessible to me
what do you think about learning a third
language by using a second language I
went through that do you start how do
you start learning okay all these
languages with different scripts you
have to learn the script and it's the
same process but just more effort into
learning the Korean Mandarin Arabic and
Japanese script do I speak Polish you
know I did kind of I understand it kind
of I can read it kind of but this it's
right now as we say in English on the
back burner I would love to get back to
it okay
yeah to find someone to speak to in
English you'd have to search the
internet do you plan to visit Slovakia
Czech Republic again I have no immediate
plans but I would love to have you ever
gotten very far in the language only to
regret picking that language and
choosing another no I can't say I have
turkey and kimchi varma we'll see if
there's any reaction from that do you
find it boy my keeps on jumping down
here hmm
[Music]
let's go back up where we lost it
alright gotta find my place I don't know
why it skips down on me
I guess I want to visit Turkey there
without it okay putting up with noises
any of the elective margin big-budget
release Sheamus knows okay why are there
more dialects in some languages than
others I think it could be historical
reasons you know what can I say I mean
there are lots of I guess if you're in
the mountains then communities were more
separated from each other I don't know
the answer to that how do I get asylum
I'm from Yemen I have no idea do you
want to come to Turkey yes learn the
third language with your language that's
not fluent that way I heard of you wish
no what do you think about shadow I
don't do it so I don't have any comment
trying right now to learn Hebrew without
the knee good how do you deal with text
without vows well I started doing some
Hebrew but then I stopped with Arabic I
don't really use the diacritics for the
vowels because we have audio we have
text-to-speech
we have audio so I can hear it again
it's a bit like some of these grammar
issues once you're starting to get
familiar with some of the words and then
you're looking at a word which you've
already seen and understand and then you
start seeing the diacritics for vowels
it's easier to remember them anyway
that's what I did I have analysis and I
wanted to up my writing language in the
shortest time go for it
how many many stories do you recommend
reading per day when you are starting
out in a new language there's no such
recommendation you start out with one it
goes very slowly at first and it
gradually starts going faster it depends
how familiar the language is like for me
now in Croatian is absolutely or Serbian
it's because I have other Slavic
languages it goes very quickly in
Persian it went very slowly my Romanian
is also one of my dormant languages I'd
have trouble speaking it now but it
wouldn't take me long to get it back
okay karema think about the best
compared to other languages why I think
one of the problems is the dictionaries
we use neighbor which is a very popular
Korean dictionary but I think it's
designed for Koreans learning English it
just is not very satisfactory the
process has been a little slower with
Korean but I'm gonna go back to Korean
and we'll see if this works better now
with what we have done okay can I upload
PDF centerlink
without audio yes and does link use
native speakers with what is uploaded I
don't understand whatever your source
audio is that's what's there if you
bring in a text without audio then the
text-to-speech will be used the
text-to-speech is what it is it's a
native speaker I don't know how that
technology works but that's what you get
I'm Portuguese and I study English but I
want to learn French you can learn them
both not a problem is it possible to
remove the repetition of the blue word
being said in link I don't understand
what you're talking about I have noticed
that online there's sometimes a bit of
an echo I could you send that message to
customer service and see we can get to
the bottom of it from Czech Republic
yeah I enjoyed it I've been away from it
for a while talking about using
comprehensive but I have had a hard time
finding and when you have zero
understanding of the new law of the new
language and that's why and when you
start the language is not comprehensible
so that's why I use the many stories
that gets you going and after that you'd
search things of interest never
discourage you when you told them you
want to learn a language like why do you
want to learn no never have anyone to
discourage me rule dingdong unity really
close it's like any language you just
have to work at it
Bonjour Steve you have any time you
German sense of humor during a
conversation they are stuck at level one
of humor well those are stereotypes that
I don't subscribe to alaikum Salaam
in summary Girma cute and chuckles I'll
again as a person speaker I like your
Persian accent thank you can I learn
French in one year yes advice and get on
Lync which language should I learn if I
speak Czech English a little bit of
German land I would like to pick some
more you have to make that decision
based on where your motivation is I
can't tell you what you're motivated to
learn okay thanks for your time learning
Egyptian Arabic by myself okay
finish round a maybe how many hours you
spend on link okay yeah two hours it
might be one and a half to two hours if
I include the listening link t-shirt we
saw I saw your comment on Twitter we're
working on something stay tuned stay
tuned we'll have something out next week
a big fan Thank You Christian
stand up for Farsi you have internet
connection use it yeah Farsi I mean see
what we have there's a Persian online I
would recommend ok you think that
English and French are main languages
nowadays well certainly English is and
French yeah there's a you know half a
dozen languages that are very very
widely spoken yeah languages that are
very similar it creates certain problems
you seem to you know I find myself
reluctant to leave the comfort of
Spanish and force myself into Portuguese
again it's all a matter of time what do
you think is that measure how many hours
you need to get to enter me I don't
really worry about it so much I just
like the process if we enjoy in the
process yeah 25
thousand words in Spanish you're
essentially at b2 now you have to start
speaking more Allah Allah
okay I'm your big fan okay I would like
to learn Farsi are there any good asks
for it well
come on link and also look up Persian
online I think about management it comes
to language on you I don't have time to
practice every day and I feel confused
about it get listening and that'll drive
the rest of your learning activity it's
not the offense that I got first or the
north liek a good hands in our sprockie
it's broken - yes I mean obviously
reading norsk is easier listening to it
not so bad Danish is harder and I wish
we could pay on link using WeChat okay I
will try to remember to speak to our
technical team about that breakfast
series breakfast series I don't know
what a breakfast series is yeah I mean
this is the advantage of the many
stories as you know the context so
therefore it's quite easy to get into a
new language a story that you already
know so you can focus on the language
and how it works
don't start learning French with just
reading sure there's no rush would you
ever consider writing a sequel to your
book it's so much work but maybe maybe
thank you for the encouragement okay I'm
waiting for you please let me know how
to improve English boy dropped it again
here you know what we're past the hour
so I'm gonna actually call it here I'm
sorry if I missed something
thank you very much sorry for the
confusion when we got started and look
forward to doing this again next week
bye for now